and we can't all live in nature but it  doesn't mean we can't live naturally and  we should be able to get our needs met  in every environment that's the point  it's just well if not we we here we're  in the rewilding circle this demonizing  kind of the zoo the human Zoo actually  it's not about demonizing the city life  it's about just dismantling  deconstructing ways of living that  aren't really serving Us in those  environments and then reconnecting to  ways of living that of course are more  in sync with our human biology like how  we can move within everyday spaces you  know if we looked at rewilding that way  in the sense that I do it's like you can  rewild your movement your gut your sleep  you know your everyday behaviors in  those experiences